in this portion of our world views and
values class we're now going to turn to
the works or at least one major work of
a very interesting Roman philosopher
from the 6th century the early 6th
century when he actually is put to death
he's writing this work the consolation
of philosophy from his prison cell
before he's actually executed he is
reflecting on what's going on and this
guy his name is Boethius his full name
is actually a Nikias manliest severino's
Boethius because romans at that time at
least upper-class romans had quite a few
names much like we do today who having
our typical three names and he's really
an important figure in in many ways
that's why we've picked him to read not
only is this work a great work in its
own right if you're devoting adequate
attention to it you're going to see that
there's some really interesting ideas
worked out here it may take a little bit
of struggle to adapt your mind to them
but if you do you're gonna find this an
incredibly productive work to examine
but he's also somebody who had an
incredible role in forming the culture
particularly the intellectual culture of
the Middle Ages and going on even into
the the later times he's read not only
by philosophers and theologians but by
monks by common people by educated
people and in all walks of life and he
goes on to influence not only you know
philosophy and theology but also the
development of literature so Chaucer
reads him for example and Dante reads
him and incorporates some ideas from
boethius into him and but we've this
this particular work especially is is
uniting two things that we often want to
totally dissociate
he is writing at the beginning of the
Middle Ages in what we often call the
Dark Ages he's actually a shining light
during that time and if you if you think
about your history what's going on is
the ancient period has drawn to a close
with the fall of Rome and that didn't
mean that everything from Rome went away
as a matter of fact educated people of
that time knew ancient philosophy and
studied it Boethius is one of the few
people in the West who can actually at
this time still read Greek most of them
are just reading and speaking Latin or
other languages and he is is taking all
of that great wisdom from now you know
several hundred years of Greek
philosophy and he's he's putting it
within the framework of Christian belief
thought and practice now in this work
you're not going to see him making
reference to Christ or to Christianity
he does that in other works because he
actually was a a practicing Christian
we'll talk a little bit about that later
what I want to stress here is that one
of the things that's very important
about we theist is that he's taking this
these two grapes currents and fusing
them together into a new synthesis and
so what he's doing he's not pitching it
as doing anything new but he is actually
doing something quite novel bringing
these things together and that's going
to leave its mark on the rest of the
Middle Ages and you can see it very
clearly reflected in this great work by
his this is one of the most popular most
often copied works of the Middle Ages
back then and if you wanted to get a new
copy of a book you had to find someone
who had a copy of the book then you had
to find somebody to copy it out or do it
yourself so you know a lot of intensive
work and and resources associated with
keeping this guy's work alive keeping
this guy's book in circulation so we
know that it influenced many people that
a lot of people saw a great value with
us and if you devote your attention to
it I think you will as well
now
after I've given you this great sales
pitch about boëthius we should start
getting to the real focus of this
particular introductory video we want to
look at three things as usual with every
work that we approach one of them is the
genre of the work another is the
historical context of the work and then
the third thing is the themes and these
all interpenetrate and and support each
other what should we say then about the
genre of this work so in a way if I ask
you about what kind of work is this what
kind of work of philosophy is this it's
a little bit of a trick question and I
don't mean a trick question in the sense
that by now you've actually realized
that philosophy isn't just one single
genre comes a lot of different varieties
it could be a dialogue it could be a
treatise it could be letters what I mean
is that there's two different things
going on in this text two different
genres that are quite different from
each other and which are brought
together they're kind of stitched at
critical points throughout the entire
work a good you know maybe one third of
the work is poetry and these poems are
meant to actually convey philosophical
ideas if you read through them they're
they're quite sophisticated that's not
poetry necessarily in the sense that
you're used to the ancients had very
different ideas about what poetry was
supposed to do how rhyme was supposed to
work but you can identify them as poetry
in part because you know they're shorter
verses right and then we have this
dialogue taking place throughout the
entire work now it's a it's a it's an
unusual dialogue why well in most
dialogues what we're dealing with is a
discussion taking place between
different characters and those different
characters are kind of all on the same
level they're supposed to be real people
at least for the purpose of the dialogue
you know if Shakespeare has a play like
Hamlet while we're watching the play
we're supposed to believe that Hamlet is
a real person doing these sorts of
things and saying these sorts of things
there's ghosts in it and all sorts of
things like that but those ghosts were
of real people at one time right the
ghost of his father in this case we have
a dialogue that's taking place between
boy theose himself the writer and
philosophy philosophy personified as a
woman philosophy able to actually speak
directly to buoy theists not philosophy
as say contained in a book but
philosophy as something living breathing
thinking and as we find out able to
consult boy feeis about what's happened
to his his life and able to lead him
into seeing things in a different way so
this is a very powerful conception here
but we want to ask ourselves what is
really going on here is Boethius really
conversing with philosophy or is he is
he really having a conversation with
himself and calling what's going on you
know him conversing with with philosophy
is it really a soliloquy or a monologue
or is it really a genuine dialogue
that's something that you have to think
about yourself and it depends on how you
understand the work of philosophy can
philosophy itself be something
personified is it something active is it
something personal now we should talk a
little bit about the poetry I am going
to say something here that that's
probably a lot of medieval scholars and
philosophers and particularly Boethius
scholars are going to you know raise a
hue and cry and want to run me out of
town for saying but I think when you're
first approaching this work you can
probably not read the poetry sections
you can probably just concentrate on the
dialogue and skip over the poetry
sections they're worth reading I do want
to stress that there's some really
beautiful and brilliant stuff going on
in them but perhaps if you have to carry
out a kind of triage and just get to the
things that you need to study the most I
would I would actually avoid the poetry
the book itself is divided and
five books five what we would call
chapters remember the ancients tended to
divide works in different ways and they
don't exactly correspond to five
different topics there's there's a
number of different topics that are kind
of bleeding over from one to the other
but you can say that the book divisions
do establish important points the first
book is lamenting his circumstances he's
saying look here's the particulars this
is really awful and philosophy saying
you know I could I can help you out here
you know you're I think you've got a
lost perspective second part is
discussing the goods of fortune third
part is still continuing this discussion
of goods and fortune but now it's
talking about the nature of human
happiness it discusses God and it starts
introducing the whole notion of
Providence in a serious way the fourth
book deals more with God more with
Providence and addresses the what we
call the issues surrounding the nature
of evil and talks about evil as a
privation the fifth book deals with a
classic problem about pre about
foreknowledge and an human choice and
freedom but there's some back and forth
between those so you want to be
attentive to that the one other thing
that I do need to say about genre is
that this work really is supposed to be
a consolation it's written by Boethius
who's written a number of other works
before this it's written from his prison
cell this is his project that he's
working on when he knows that at any
time the executioner could show up and
his life has been up to that point
before it is imprisonment it's been a
pretty good life and it's it's it's
shattered it's it's turned upside down
and he's trying to use the philosophy
that has been the centerpiece of his
existence to to really make sense of
things
so philosophy is consoling him but
philosophy is not just consoling him by
saying I look on the bright side
or it's you know that's not as bad as it
seems because it's pretty bad philosophy
is saying you're only going to be happy
if you fundamentally change your way of
looking at things you've fallen away
from from what it is that's most true
and you don't really understand your own
nature and your own position in the
cosmos and if you do understand those
things this is not going to seem bad to
you so that's the the genre that we're
talking about here let's look now at the
historical context so this is a
fascinating time what we're talking
about is Rome and the Roman Empire after
its fall now you might say well how can
we be talking about the Roman Empire
after the Roman Empire has fallen these
barbarians came in you remember this
from your history classes no doubt
the barbarians come in these Germans and
they're divided into a bunch of tribes
and they establish kingdoms here and
there so you know Visigoths and
Ostrogoths and and these guys and those
guys and they go to war with each other
occasionally over in the east there's
still the the Eastern Roman Empire
what's called the Byzantine Empire and
they every once in a while mess around
with what's going on in the West this is
before the rise of Islam so that's not a
third player on the scene yet but it's
not really the case that you've got a
Roman Empire in the east and just a
bunch of barbarian kingdoms in the West
why is that well one of the things that
occurs is the collapse of some
institutions the collapse of some
political rule but the reincorporation
within these barbarian kingdoms of
whatever they could get their hands on
and that doesn't just mean books that
doesn't just mean people that means
institutions that means traditions that
means power structures there's still a a
Senate
in place even after Rome has fallen
because boëthius is part of it
they still have councils his two sons
take the role of consoles which was an
extremely important position in the
ancient Roman Empire you might say why
is it still going on because when these
are bearing invaders came through they
wanted to hold on to much of what they
conquered they didn't just want to come
in and ruin everything raze it to the
ground establish their own culture they
recognized that there were a lot of
superior aspects and dimensions to the
culture that they're coming into and
they said we want to hold on to this as
much as we can so the successor culture
was one that incorporates and continues
a lot of things from antiquity but it
does so in different ways so for example
the the Senate is going to come into
conflict with the king with the Royal
Council at a certain point and you've
got all these sort of you know what's
going to happen to this what's going to
happen to this going on at this time all
these adaptations education was still
being carried out and it was still being
carried out in traditional ways
institutions were still in place
Boethius himself is a guy who at this
time not only is engaged in politics
working for the Visigoth king no I'm
sorry the Ulster gotthe king theodoric
but he is also continuing the process of
education he has the intention of
translating all of Plato and Aristotle
works he managed to do this with a few
of them into from Greek into Latin
because he realizes if culture is going
to continue here in the West we need to
adapt it's sort of like saying you know
imagine that that America and the entire
english-speaking world collapsed
overnight someone else would come in and
we have a lot of great ideas and great
works
and they might want to translate those
into whatever successor language is
going to be coming after that
notice that the successor language is
not gothic it's not a Germanic language
it's Latin because they're continuing to
use Latin as the base for everything in
the West another thing that we need to
point out about historical context is we
often think of the Middle Ages as a time
where where the Christian Church ruled
everything but that's really not the
case it's not as if you had you know
Greek and Roman antiquity and then that
just somehow ended and then Christianity
had come on the scene and it wasn't
really that strong but it managed to
take over the Roman Empire and now that
was just the only religion as a matter
of fact there were some incredibly
bitter disputes going on within the
Christian world over how Christianity
should be interpreted there were what we
nowadays call heresies comes actually
from the word hey graces which means
choice which which split the entire
Christian world arianism was a good
example of that the Aryans actually held
that that Christ was just a creature not
God incarnate so you can see that that's
very different than you know what we
nowadays think of us as modern-day
contemporary Christians and the Aryans
actually managed to take control over
some some pretty significant areas
sometimes they had entire kingdoms where
that was the the predominant form of
Christianity there were also struggles
between East and and West the the two
churches the the Roman Church and the
the Byzantine church were not always
seeing eye-to-eye on things and there's
a lot of conversations that we can have
there it's very complex issue
looks like boethius himself actually ran
into some of those politics and that may
be part of what what motivated his
execution ultimately but what I want to
point out here is that
Christianity was not the sort of
monolithic Church that we often
associate with caricatures of the Middle
Ages there are a lot of different things
going on Buie theist himself is a great
example of an educated Christian who
sees no problem bringing together
ancient pagan philosophy and Christian
thought and seeing connections between
the two of them
notice that the pagan philosophers
because you're not going to see any
references to Christ in this actually
believe in the existence of a god a god
whose transcendent who creates and
providentially orders everything who's
all good who wants us to be virtuous
this looks a little awful lot like like
what the Christians are teaching we
can't get away from when we're talking
about historical context as well we
can't get away from what's actually
happening to boëthius so we should tell
a little bit about that story so be
theists as I put it out he's coming from
an ancient Roman family from the
patricians or the elite class and he is
taking part in in politics he's very
well educated he's adopted by another
guy from the patrician class a marcus
after his own father dies and he's
raised by him so Marcus also reads Greek
so be theists perhaps learns in
association with him and Bowie theist is
a great example of a person who's
willing to straddle the active world of
administration politics culture and the
what we might call the academic world of
learning of philosophy of the life of
the mind and he's working with both of
those at the same time it's not the
philosophy that's going to get him in
trouble though it's his association with
some of the people of his own time but
we this appears to have been a genuinely
upstanding person and he gets himself in
trouble because the Senate one of the
one of the members of the Senate
accused of treachery of actually dealing
with just with with the the the Roman
Emperor over in the in the east who had
all these designs on you know taking
parts of Italy so you've got a power
struggle going on there and it'd be like
being accused of treason here in the
United States today you're you're too
close with those people over there
you're gonna let them in you're gonna
help them defeat us and and Byzantine
the Byzantine Empire was a very powerful
force at that time it would be sort of
like you know collaborating with a
rising China or you know a renaissance
Russia at this time not like you know
say collaborating with North Korea it's
like collaborating with a great power
who could swallow you up and so there's
this an informer who as boy theist talks
about you know it's telling these people
hey this guy is a trainer and boy FINA
says well look if he's a traitor then
we're all traitors because you know the
whole Senate is involved in in this sort
of process and the Senate you know they
they kind of backed away and they let
Boethius hang and Booey theist now gets
arrested along with this this other
person and arrested at that time meant
first he was confined in a church and
then he sent out to this this far-off
country estate so he's not actually like
in a prison cell that has bars and stuff
like that but he can't go anywhere and
he's effectively exiled he's effectively
under house arrest he's there for about
a year before they finally execute him
and they execute him because they see
him as being a threat to the power
structure later on they're actually
going to also execute his father-in-law
and the fortunes of his family are going
to decline as a result so that's the
historical context for this work he is
writing it under a very real sentence of
death you know he doesn't know exactly
what's when it's going to happen he
knows that it's unfair he he sees that
you know acting the right way being a
good person doesn't always pay off he's
had a pretty good life up until this
point fortune has been favoring him but
now it's gone completely against him and
he's upset he's understandably upset so
that's the context for this work let's
talk now about the themes what are some
of the key ideas what are some of the
key things that are going on in this
work well you see that it's very
personal there's he's talking about his
circumstances and philosophy itself is
personified here is a woman who can
converse with with Boethius so
philosophy is being understood not as an
abstract doctrine but as something that
really affects us something that can can
give us the the way to think about
what's going on in our life what's how
to relate our lives to the wider broader
universe ultimately even to the divine
that's that's what philosophy is able to
do there's also this notion of healing
through philosophy that philosophy is
going to be able to provide him not just
consolation and sort of like an opiate
or a sense of well it's not so bad I'm
gonna hang out with you philosophy can
actually get to the root of things and
make him feel not only better not only
okay but actually happy there's a
another key theme about the goods of
fortune are they really the goods that
we take them to be wealth property fame
power are these things really as good as
we make them out to be and then he's
going to talk about the nature of
genuine happiness what is it that will
really satisfy it satisfy us what will
really make us happy it's going to turn
out that that is actually God and again
this is not a a Christian tract although
it's very compatible with Christianity
this is coming from ancient philosophy
he's drawing on Plato he's drawing on
Aristotle he's drawing on the Stoics
another key idea is going to be that
that God providentially orders
everything and then it raises another
connected question
well then wines are things so screwed up
what is what is going on with evil why
do evil people seem to prosper what is
the nature of evil finally we're going
to talk about one other issue the
compatibility between two things that
seem to be totally irreconcilable that
is divine foreknowledge God being will
see what's going to happen in the future
and human free will
are these really compatible or aren't
they so those are key themes that we're
gonna see being worked out in this book
again you know one last thing to say if
you have to work your way through this
and you're a little bit short on time I
would just skip over the poetry because
there's so much meat there in the
philosophical dialogue so much rich fare
that it's going to take you a little bit
of time to to digest that that will be
enough to occupy